[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
[Applause]
okay last time you're on yeah you hit us
with that uh that question
simple i said apples you got to hit us
with another question today well well
again
you don't have to do it immediately save
me for what you want to say i'll come up
with it
you got to come over i love that yeah
but this time no
trickery straight forward
i just get a kick out of brennan because
i can tell like he's doing this watch
this he's just starting he's
he looks at me and he goes he's looking
at my clothes and he looks at my hair
and he just takes me in i ate shake it i
ate grated cheese last night
too late i went i go good i went on an
empty stomach we were on a cheese bender
all night
because daddy looks tired daddy ate a
lot see now
getting older daddy's in spot today
oscar the grouch okay
well i got a little you got three shirts
you got three shirts
no man i got you you have a wife eater
like an old italian
no for me i like having two layers
because it makes me feel like i'm a
little thicker
oh i get it i like that i get it i wear
black to look thinner
yeah you do right everyone i mean
everyone does that every everybody has
and also you know big guys can't wear uh
horizontal stripes like it'd make even
you guys look bigger
really yeah horizontal on camera yeah i
won't do that
if everyone on tv don't wear horizons oh
i won't do that you look insanely big
i already know how much i weigh 275.
that's a lot of weight
hey how about we're talking i was like i
need to lose weight and i was like i'm
like 272. not anymore i'm down 10.
but he's like yeah i'm about 250 if i
went
but you're not though because hey i'm
55. you're not good
maybe 2600. i don't think so man i
literally thought i was 255 people lie
about their weight and their height
no i wasn't lying i just thought no he
literally didn't know
yeah yeah two seven two you saw it on
him
he brought a scale in oh you did yeah
yeah he's dance
you're dead and then he sent
uranium is dense if you were to pick up
a piece of
aluminum it's very light okay
i'm with you weapons grade uranium like
if we're at a party
that's how if we're at a party calendar
is like moving potato chips yeah
you're like moving the melted cheese
that's right it's [ __ ] okay yeah
you're sick
you try to use uranium and all this
stuff strong though and almost 100
percent
fast twitch that's what you say to
people but i i listen i said
cormier i sent the uh before oh he said
before and after picks
we have a group chat brave all i said is
you got to see
it all i said is that gut though
what that can do you put you put weight
on uniformly though
i mean it kind of goes all the way it's
kind of but i can't really tell but his
shoulders and chest
he's you know but that's my problem
brian that's my problem
is that i it doesn't look like bad but
and your girl
i text her i said i said sweetheart i
weighed 275.
she goes how much did you think you
weighed yeah
no she knows she was just like you're
her big duh but we're saying that's
her big man yeah yeah like her big panda
bear yeah
i'm i'm like taking a nap and you like
kung fu panda i'm not a
kung fu panda you're a big kung fu panda
emma
well you're saying hey have you ever
hey brian now have you ever met malek's
girl
well hello brendan here's the thing man
hello everybody
take it easy take it easy man his hands
watch his hands his hands fast
he'll catch up with his hands because we
went to dinner we went to dinner with
the girls
she's a beautiful one you got a lot of
water wait
he's already said it no but but it's a
good wipe it's good white yeah
she's she's a beautiful woman oh no
she's pretty for sure oh yeah
why wait don't say it like
[Applause]
i see potential that's what you see i
see i see a human being so when you
watch an nba game what do you see
that's the white coach just steve nash
he's watching the nets like wow look at
the white guy i follow the ball
i love that i've already seen the
difference i was talking to
this black guy it was in virginia beach
and i you know me i take in people and i
i look at this guy sitting there i go
well that's how i want to be built
that's an athlete
that just looks like an athlete he's got
gold teeth down here
oh turns out one of the servers is his
cousin so he comes over
such a nice guy and in fact starts
talking about how he wants to he's kind
of like a local tough guy and he wants
to fight
he's 31 and i go late in the game i'm
like little late in the game
though looks like an athlete i mean you
look you know you guys i fight
heavyweight i go how much weight was 220
i go you fight 185
yeah you're one that's right you're
you're you're 185
and we started talking and um and he
he was he's just talking and he's just
in a good mood
and he literally went like this he goes
he goes man
everybody's so nice to black people now
i love them
that's the if that's the result of this
[ __ ] that's that's [ __ ] pretty i'm
happy
that's very good yeah yeah he was cool
man he like he felt like
saint petersburg petersburg yeah that
part of virginia well i was
i remember when i was in virginia beach
last time i we
we smoked weed and i'm not a big weed
smoker how long ago is this
this is when i was uh i was 20 right
so that was like when the civil war was
man i'm asking
1812 right they had the telegraph
now at this time were there separate
fountains for
brown versus board of education
[Laughter]
i will say i'm old enough i am old
enough so that when i was
younger and if you saw a white woman
married to a black dude
it was like hmm oh for sure oh yeah you
know what i mean
like it was like oh my aunt made a white
uh black dude like
black black like bald black
yeah yeah and my grandma didn't talk to
her anymore
that's just she's just so old and you
can't
like when they're stuck in those ways
they can't change them no yeah well this
woman was talking such a shame she was
the
mother of my my friend and she said she
did this
she was like and you know and so she was
doing this and then something happened
to her but i'm danny and she married a
black guy so she was
and uh we're like well whoa whoa what is
what is that which means you're a little
phooey yeah yeah they're still not stuck
though
like what like yeah no but but i mean
these guys both
are caucasian women yeah my favorite is
like it's not about racism it's a little
bit about like so when you hear things
like this you hear this about
um they're talking about this white this
is my impression of white guys talking
about a black
black person like this is how they this
is
this is this is how they this is how
they describe somebody being smart
uh and he's very articulate very
articulate you know you're like
oh so he speaks clearly yeah
that is true there's a little details
but but we're making progress
it's all fun and games like on king this
thing we had this uh guy calling
and uh he's in a tesla and he's talking
about how him and his wife have been
together for seven years
and he's like you know there's just no
like the sex is terrible we're too
familiar with each other we have kids
and
he's like she's down for an open
relationship bringing a screen i went oh
that that that sounds fun bubbling you
open that he goes yeah i mean it could
be fun to mix it up michael yeah she
like talked about anyone she's into he's
like yeah this guy jerome like
big black dick come in that house and
when you see your girlfriend with double
hands
motorbike in that thing double hand
motorbike no you're working
cheese yeah
yeah and that exists out there and you
can see it on his face he's like
yeah you're right man it's not a good
idea it's not bad water to the water a
little deep for you yeah pour a little
deep
yeah that's when you it just makes you
work harder i embrace that kind of
challenge and i endorse that kind of
activity
what do you mean straight away oh you're
talking about that sometimes when i'm
sorry nobody wants to talk about this
when the relationship is stagnant need a
little danger
need a little danger so what are you
kidding me uh you're so you'd be open to
if you're with your girl i want to talk
to the three of you guys
after the show what what oh you want you
want the kids and
and and big fake hair to take a spin on
your girl
and i'll have coffee
[Applause]
like the other guys were fine but that
big brown one it's not like
coffee he's really mean he didn't take
his glasses off here that i said that
and you guys got quiet
you guys went i did it what i was off i
went i went i was just i go you know i
want to talk to you guys about
you know and you guys went they tensed
up yeah i mean well that's like saying
listen a lot of black dudes get asked
for that cuck holding [ __ ] is that true
oh yes yeah hell yeah oh yeah yeah it's
not like like you guys had it
bro i had an application yeah i did i
filled this out
i told you what my mom's off you now
she's on malik
we're in a group chat with my aunt nubby
and my mom because i always sent a
picture of the kids and my mom went
that malick is just good looking i get
that i i would be we'd be on the road
and i'd get that
it's when you realize you're older now
you get lost in my eyes we know there's
my charisma but what not since you got
the lids done
no i know it makes you know you [ __ ]
up
hey exactly
what a waste of time and resources
listen man
when you get older it's like that you're
i'm 54.
it ain't getting better next year no the
only thing you could do bubba is you got
to go real serious and we get we're
going to cut scalp a little bit and pull
everything back
what you got to do is when you do a
facelift okay please understand this
for men whatever reason it's way more
complicated than women
now for men you have to understand
you're getting your face taken off like
the movie face like i love
movies yeah they take it off they take
it oh because because they got to move
everything back and move everything back
the entire face
yeah now while while the surgeon i know
was doing that for a man it was a
13-hour operation
the black lives matter protests yeah
that turned into a riot in beverly hills
where they were breaking the windows
and they were he's on the second floor
and they were breaking the windows of
the pharmacy on the first floor and
coming in
guys he's got the guy's got the face off
he's like i got another four hours
five hours to put this guy's face back
on oh my gosh
and somehow they kind of just kept going
i mean ah break it in yeah
his face is off yeah yeah give him his
sugar that's the last thing you think
sorry your face i'm sorry that your face
it's a major
maze so what happened to him they fixed
it they fixed it he said it turned out
great but that that
[ __ ] are you gonna do that i sure am not
oh okay i'm just making sure dude you
can't no no no no no
no no no look man i'm a little swell
you can't i [ __ ] ate great you keep
saying that from a spoon
i knew it was gonna kill me it was it
was 11 o'clock i'm watching that
documentary on crack
and i'm oh snowfall do you see that uh
um no that's the nfx show
on netflix no what's it called documents
right on crack the war on drugs
we're on black people no you call the
war on drugs yeah
especially was the 70s it was actually
the uh
1880s so cocaine 2834 was uh
predominantly a white drug because it's
more expensive and then crack was the
cheap drug
and they made the laws for crack way
worse yeah
so that's what my dad was selling and
black people so they went to prison for
a long [ __ ] time
yes and as in if you had this much crack
so you if you got that as
a white kid you you you know hey man
don't do that yeah you didn't go to jail
if you were if you were
22 i remember this so well i remember it
so well my buddy was in jail for a
little bit and i went to visit him
and he said see that guy and i saw this
young like athletic looking black kid
who was like 22.
he was doing a 23-year stretch because
he was selling crack
they made it really hard on black i'm
talking about people people were put
away
yeah for 20 and 30 years 15 years
minimum sentencing the rockefeller laws
yes the judge couldn't the judge
literally couldn't do it again
there was a guideline that's how it was
it was called the war on drugs
and so what happened was you were taking
dads out of the home
you were taking brothers out of the home
you were taking sons out of the home
yeah and they they came back and they
and then to add
insult to injury so now you come out and
it's been i don't know
uh 20 years you've got no skills and you
have a felony on your record you've got
a felony
you're not getting housing you can't
even live with your mom no because your
mom lives in a in a project
your mom lives in an association
whatever it is and they don't want a
felon in there so you can't even live
with your mother you can't live with
your family so now guess where you live
on the street you literally just told my
dad's story yep
well definitely that's literally exactly
everything you just said right there
i'm sure he tried getting a job going to
get out oh my god yeah
he tried to but it was so impossible and
he he wanted to do right because
he wanted to get back in uh into minding
my brother's uh
life yeah right he was he was trying
real hard but he goes
everywhere was rejecting me he goes but
the only way i knew how to make money
and you know he goes i you know i'll
just try to do it for a little bit and
make some money
to get home to get on my feet and you
know be back in you guys lives
but uh is that when he got caught he
ended up getting caught
well you go back he did a total he did a
total of 17 17 years
gee warehouse just warehouse yeah
and you can never raise your kids well
yeah the big one a lot of people aren't
well i mean guys
it's kind of getting attention but you
know they passed uh
marijuana in new jersey the offseason
pastor in california
arizona arizona new york's gonna pass it
but what's [ __ ] up is just guys locked
down for long stretches for marijuana
and it's like so hold on so you're going
to change the rules to because you the
the economy needs money so you can
change the rules on weed but then what
about these guys
because now you're cool with it and
because they did when it wasn't cool now
they're
they'd lose their [ __ ] lives yeah and
their dads and their brothers
anytime you have a massive government
movement like what you got to be very
careful with these things the war on
terror
that that that war has been going on for
17 18 years right
yeah and iraq out now to the tune of
over 11 trillion dollars
because you gotta understand say it
again eleven trillion trillion thousand
that's a thousand billion
thousand trillion a thousand billion a
billion seconds
thirty three bezos don't have that one
billion seconds is 33 years
so if you're real lucky you might lift
three billion seconds if you're real
lucky
usually most people live two billion
because i guess about a thousand billion
a thousand billion so 11 000 billion
try to put that in mind on the wars the
middle east was which have been expanded
and what happens is there's money in it
there's money in fighting drugs there's
money in fighting
terrorism and so when you when you label
something more on drugs that war on
terror you better be
you better be very careful and you
better look at who's actually doing the
dying
who's doing the dying it's funny who's
doing the suffering so [ __ ] you we
always had conversations about this but
we all can agree that cia put crack or
cocaine in
our neighborhood right uh well that's
what well that's i don't know i've heard
that
yeah i i i don't see the my problem with
simplified you got to be careful also
with gone the cia did
it might have been rogue elements so so
there are rogue elements in any
group that can make money off stuff like
this okay i don't know i just know that
cocaine is big money it is cocaine is
big money and the biggest it's a billion
dollar business a year it's a 11 billion
business a year for the cartel and you
know the number one
consumer america of course that's what
so it's like so it's a huge market
so youth like could we take out the
cartel in a week
and release the special force hounds on
them for sure yeah
again it's 11 billion dollar business
yeah and so it starts from the top
though if you want to eliminate drugs
there's other fires to put out
i think also you've got if you have the
big you're not stopping who
good luck stopping everybody from doing
cocaine yeah
we know this have you have you heard
read the book the silk road
no they came out with a movie on it they
said moving on steve he's actually good
friends with the guy
old rich or whatever but his concept
i i vibe with i [ __ ] with it so he
started in austin
and he had all these failed like careers
and stuff and he was like what i want to
do
is uh basically amazon for drugs where
it's a safe marketplace
because he believes in you know freedom
of speech everything like you have the
will
if you want to do drugs do drugs so he
he had good intentions
but then and it was all bitcoin so the
way bitcoin works and the way
the silk road work you couldn't fault
you couldn't track it
so you had bad guys trading stuff on
there because start off as like a
community in austin
and they you know sell shrooms and you
know uh ecstasy and marijuana and people
were getting these packages i couldn't
believe it
then it blew up he did an interview on
gawker and it just blew the [ __ ] up
and he was making i think they said over
seven million dollars a day
once it started he was making seven
million dollars a day but uh
have you ever thought i have a question
but here's the thing so
it's all fun and games but that's just
not the way it works
so you know what he's doing now he's a
double life sentence
crazy double lifestyle but but then
but this is where he gets dicey and this
is where i mean stevie disagree
stevie's like oh do you really think you
should get live for that i'm like
i don't think he got life for his
business aspirations and
having an open market for drugs he got
life because
as he kept going he was doing murder for
hire
he wanted to kill two guys and there's
an informant as uh
fbi agent was undercover got on there
learned the system
and became friends with him and was text
him like
you know what do you this guy's gonna
[ __ ] it's over what do you want to do
and he's like kill him for me
so they have it two twice
yeah by the way that's that's murder yes
that's what i said
but here's the thing so that fbi agent
faked the murder obviously he wasn't
really killing it so he faked and sent
the guy pictures
but that that owner ulrich's uh
intentions
he he all for all he knew is that guy
was murdered
even though they're like the murders
never happened like it doesn't matter
he thinks they didn't ordered those
murderers
but that's their defense like but they
never no nobody was killed like it
doesn't matter his intentions
as far as he knows have you ever been on
the it's very interesting you're
bringing this up
have you been on the dark web uh no no
no no no
i mean back pain life is dark enough
because somebody brought me on that dark
web
by somebody who's fam tripoli nope this
weekend
what would you do by accident uh oh i i
don't want to get into it
it's basically the silk road it's still
going on dude you can order whatever you
want
he goes there's whatever you think is
the economy
on our regular thing because i he goes
there's a there's an economy you can and
i don't know if it's illegal to even be
on there i don't know
no you do ip scramblers he was shown i
said i want to see this he was showing
me
he was showing me like they so that you
have you have to have an ip scrambler
you have to have
all this different you know stuff but
there is a
i don't know there's a multi-billion
dollar maybe trillion dollar economy 100
going on on all the drugs
you can well so so murder you can watch
murder videos you're a drug dealer
you can have drugs pure drugs sent to
your
home yeah and when something apparently
is sent to your home
you can't get in trouble for it because
you didn't send it as long as you don't
sign the package
yes yeah yeah something like that right
so
i was looking at all i mean and so you
think well you get ripped off
no it's a it's a it's a system where it
goes into escrow the money goes to
escrow like with um
i guess with like a house or something
ebay or something yeah
but there's a middle point you can
you got you know uh beating up people
for hire you got
and then you got i apparently and i i
you know apparently
the child pornography on that [ __ ]
thing
is so beyond what people realize so it's
a real problem
but have you noticed it's like i i only
heard about it on i think with sam
harris talking about it
like we don't even understand what's
really people don't realize how big
child porn is and like child
sex trafficking is super big though yeah
but you notice a lot of those rings and
obviously it's barely making dent but a
lot of those rings are getting taken out
you see it on the news but they don't
give credit to anybody but it's that
the the epstein's girl who they have in
prison right now
she's telling them who to go after and
you'll notice a lot of them getting
taken out right now yeah is that true
behind the scenes though it's good yeah
they don't give her credit
every week someone's getting busted
there are rings it's hurt yeah
rings of people that that communicate
with each other and
trade child pornography and what that
means is that those children are being
exploited somewhere
somewhere so there's a whole system
going on yeah but it's drugs it's
weapons
it's exotic animals it's great it's an
entire
ecosystem you got a whole tiger out
there oh you've got everything whatever
you want
whatever you want it's categories you
can even watch people get killed
yeah it's horrifying well i think about
like the like when it comes
like to jared the fogle the subway dude
yeah like he couldn't be
been the only person the other other
people get caught up with him
they find they they're so they're
they're so you have to show if you want
to be in a group
you have to show a an image of
a you with a child or a some child being
exploited
and it has to be current so you have to
prove that it's current
it's not old that you didn't get it from
something else that you are the one who
originated somehow yeah there are all
kinds of [ __ ]
there are all dif there's world there's
a thing called world market there's
another thing
all different markets all over the place
and i was just like i i
and i said i go am i allowed to are we
allowed to be on this [ __ ] yeah yeah
you're not getting in trouble for being
on there
but in the in the us these young smart
younger smart millennials who are doing
this they're they're even
a step ahead of the government as far as
that stuff goes yeah
like they'll catch them eventually but
yeah they're on to the next thing yeah
so is the cartel like that you know
especially when trump was president he
locked down the borders and wouldn't let
anybody come in
they were saying this detective and uh
feds were saying
no one adapts better than the cartel
like we can shut down whatever you want
they
always always find a way to dabble and
get drugs through
yeah yeah they're like it's unbelievable
like most don't like we'll take we'll
cut this leg out from underneath them
and you know they do figure they do all
right and then we take another leg then
they're [ __ ]
cartel we take one leg goes right back
because when you talk about the cartel
you're talking about the highest levels
of government in the military and
if there's that much money if it's a
billion if you're gonna make a billion
dollars
if i say to you and you're working in
the government or whatever and i go
i'll give you a million dollars yeah
yeah but the risk is high
but also one time they get cut but also
think how much money they think how much
money there is and you look at the big
far
farms the business they're doing the
money they're making so if you legalize
all drugs like
most people agree with then they'd miss
out on that money
so that you know the dark money of all
that billion dollars
because because the car you want to cut
the cartel's legs out yeah legalize
drugs i think stores popping up and
those cartels are [ __ ]
that's why americans are like we're just
gonna make our own [ __ ] you know people
are gonna get high
what just make them legal make them and
zone it and tax it yeah and correct
and make money and make money and bring
the economy back but that's violence
that way as well 100 percent of course
it does because if you make the
penalties that strong
the people willing to take those risks
are
bad people they're going to kill to get
that you know they have to win
the dark code of card yeah they have to
you know that's why i got out of the
trade
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait-wait
you're a little drunk
where do you think i've been not on the
tournament i didn't know you've been
doing this whole time
[ __ ] yeah
can you imagine you're smuggling drugs
in that old ass
oh [ __ ] gray like yeah wait no don't
know what the why is
i can't and no are not in my past
pack it in fellas pack it in amigos
i'm an equal opportunity employer i
don't see color
dude that's a [ __ ] source that's a
slogan that's a slogan
they call them the great mule on the web
oh great
that's a great news
yeah great weather we're the worst
frame wrinkly gray mule yeah fill them
up boys
how do we get whatever you got yeah how
do we get the contraband across
borders it's a lot of stuff get the old
ring get the gray mule
[Music]
you got my stuff you got my stuff they
give you the leather belt in your mouth
all right has your teeth marks on it
they're all dipped in some lube yeah
i got the loop it's for the monitor well
y'all getting intense with this
this is a movie scene it's a movie zero
darkness
zero dark dirty starring
the opening scene is called the rings
they called the rinks
yeah cause you come out one man you show
me all the stuff and i'm like
all right give me a minute do you know
how the movies are about one man
a lot of drugs one man one hole
you can't fill him up enough this guy
can take it all
and he will wallow one man save the game
no i'm into it you're into it you're a
sick movie that's a dope ass move
zero dark dirty
he's the candy man you got to clean them
drugs off though
clean them off real good oh wow then the
other scene of people fighting
well i need my fix that's when me and
chappelle come in yeah what yeah
yeah yeah i could play this you guys are
actors yeah i can play a little
crackhead
you can play crackhead i'm a sick
because yeah i play cranky you know
man i don't got it today all right i'm
like what you mean i'm gonna be
cheeseburger eddie come on mouse
suck your dick man come on man
and next you know the scene you see him
just give him hit now here's the thing i
won't give you head
but i'll wash your car like a cracker
you're faking it you're watching oh you
bro
that's cheeseburger no cheeseburger
cheeseburger is from uh longest yard
terry crews is just jacked yeah steroids
right there
there he is come on man come on man i
got these
cheeses and then you know they're the
good cheeseburgers too it's like greasy
bags
i don't know oh man oh that's minnesota
he was unbelievable come on man oh brian
you seen it
yeah medicine society yeah what was your
favorite well jenner's when i was you
know
what was your favorite scene yeah i
think
i did i know i think the uh yeah i think
the
most powerful thing was when you i think
it was ice cube
and you went out to it wasn't ice cream
who was it when you see him when you see
him that's all right
when she goes i feel sorry for your mama
yeah
dehumanized how dehumanized they were
yep that was so [ __ ] i feel sorry for
your mother
and he would he would have got out okay
till he said that so he said that just
take all right man
that's what he was the guy who and then
he went and shot the i love how you said
at the end the guy disappeared
can't you help me with this oh what
happened
his thing went limp what the heck this
[ __ ] went limp
oh god i had a yeah i had a uh
i got a ticket today a parking ticket
because i didn't get outside in time
and uh it was the best parking ticket
i've ever got
yeah where are you living where you got
to pay for parking on the street venice
it was street cleaning and i have yeah
venice don't [ __ ] around
oh you parked up oh was today wednesday
the street yeah yeah
i bought a prius for a for somebody i
really
and then they got it stolen yep you
don't bought it you got the money back
for insurance
no it cost me a lot of money everything
about it cost me a lot of money i was
just driving one day and i
this guy who you know he's been he was
in the war and he's veteran yeah
i want to help him out he's going to be
driving and i go it's crazy i'll go i'm
going to buy i'm going to buy this
person a car well you're going to lease
him in the car
and then what he did he went oh thanks
for i bought it but i bought it oh you
bought it
he so he's like oh my nice guy car the
guy went cool brian thanks
went into a store and they left the keys
in the car unlocked
and somebody said something it just it
was just bad and then they they [ __ ]
it up
i had to have an okay made i'd have
fixed it it was a disaster but it
doesn't matter
now i have a car and you have the prius
yeah you can really try to move it at
times but
uh no i got the testing okay i'm still
on the left you drove that you're going
to sell that lease
release is a hard break but you can't
break them they're like oh no you can
break them just give us the
eight payments you owe for the rest of
the year okay what and o'brien overpaid
because i don't pay attention no no cars
i also don't pay attention to numbers
enough and i need to yeah i'm like i
know
he and i are the worst this way and
[ __ ] uh
but the the guy was giving me the tick i
come out ah he goes
i'm sorry man i already took the picture
i hate when they do that yeah they do
they always say that is there not a
delete
button and he looks at me and he goes he
goes but i'll tell you what if you pay
this in the next 40
48 hours they'll take 20 off and i go
you're a good man and he goes you're an
honorable man that's right
i don't think that ever happened you
just go you're just trying to tell him
you just trump my
my compliment right so i'm looking at
him as he's writing it
and he's an older man and he's tight
he's put together i mean put together
ethnicity i don't see color okay
let me think i remember if it was a
shade it was a shade what's the shade he
had
he had a green brown you know it's
whatever that
color is yeah and that tends to look
good yeah that tends to go with
it might be cheeseburger darker color a
darker skin i don't know sure yeah
maybe let's go with it and i go i go you
stay in shape though
and he you know me and he goes oh yeah
always
and i said he goes and i said you're
staying safely always
67 years old and i went damn i go you're
67 i go what's your secret
and he goes and points to god
uh-huh and i go god sent him workouts
always envy people that have i could
tell
that he had complete faith and he's
writing and i said i said yeah man you
know i always think about how lucky i am
he goes nah luck is for people in vegas
you're blessed you're blessed because
you didn't sleep on the street this is
full conversation
and then you need to go yeah yeah super
blessed
did you see my 2020 though no super
blessed but
right i just want to run some [ __ ] buy
it let's tell you how blessed i am but
because 2020 was
tough dude tough but i could see this
dude who was so
he was so put together and so
positive and so disciplined so [ __ ]
discipline yeah you look at a
67 year old man like that he's been
through exactly
yeah respect been through i literally i
was like and then he said something else
and he said uh you have a great day huh
and
it's all up here and just whatever and i
was like thank you and he just took off
with his little prius
[ __ ] it he beat my ass he beat your ass
67.
[ __ ] yeah i it just just by his just
i like when old guys are jacked like in
really good shape because you think how
tough it is to get in good shape when
you're like
50 and 60. this stuff now yeah it's hard
right now
and it's little details we always talk
about like everything about like the way
his hair it was like military yeah
which may have come from being the other
way when he was on the streets
who knew right he knows maybe he was in
the military yeah or he
had a crazy life and now he's he's hot
he's happy talking but no just just
direct yeah i mean he obviously you're
purely
situation because you got a ticket and
you were happy about it
i was pretty [ __ ] good i went thank
you have a great day come back tomorrow
god bless i never said god bless i'm not
even religious god bless you
god bless you would you believe this
3 16 jesus says because sometimes the
same people make you feel so good about
the world you're like why can't the
whole world be like that
i if i had if i you know what i went
through i was in the shower and i was
like this i was fantasizing about being
jeff bezos
and i was like this and i was like i
want to be like hey you know what you
know what guess what i'm going to do
what i'm buying you a house sir
and i'm going to buy you a car yeah i'm
going to buy you all the furniture
because you're worth it i had a whole
fantasy daddy's not ready for that
though
no i'm not no i'm not but i want to be i
want to get in the way
no no no i want the time to buy random
people houses
daddy needs to take care of herself i
get excited though you see i get
emotional i know yeah
you were there i was locked in thank god
you didn't promise him anything how
about how about
you a house he's all where what
now you're locked in [ __ ] how about i
was that i was at our gym zoo gym
yesterday and i wanted to get my
headphones in i'm working out and
against older black dude in shape some
dime piece girl he's taking her through
a workout
and he goes hey man and i'm like what he
was hey man i tell you i guess
bet you glad you moved to austin now
i get people doing that all the time
like no austin for you you're not
following joe i'm like yeah no
yeah he was like bet you're glad now
aren't you and i was like i know and
he's like yeah apart he goes
he's funny goes now people are dying now
i'll get down with that because i don't
want that to happen because
there's a little bit of me that relishes
in them suffering right now
i see i hear you yeah well but like
let's talk about
texas for a second like it's cool and
you have texas
now now around austin you're going to be
paying the same prices
because everybody's moving down there
practically right i mean the whole
you got all the oh it's going up yeah
and and then also
i don't know if anybody's been in austin
between june and september but
i don't mind hot but i mean that's a
valley but but
also the other point is is like if
you're looking depending what
tax bracket you're in if your house is
in let's say in senior woodland hills
here for what you can't afford and then
you go to austin you want the same house
you're paying the same dude you're gonna
save on state taxes that's right but
you know that's people's biggest thing
is state taxes
yeah well it's a while but which is nice
for sure that's okay
ultimately bet against california not
when it has the beach in this time oh
just about you can't when it comes
popping man
when he comes popping back like there's
a reason did you did you ever think
about moving austin or were you you know
everybody's
talking about it but i think the created
the creative
uh avenues to go out here like so many
creatives know so many people with the
positive energy
i love that spirit in l.a you can't get
that in austin i agree with you there i
mean they're two and a half you could
build it i mean they're gonna have more
of that with rogan the rest of those
people following them it'll be a nice i
should get rid of
girls moving out there yeah maybe you're
gonna have a
the worst case you're gonna have a hub
because you have more creatives there
and they're gonna build
sugar and one thing we know about
cigarette and rogaine they don't miss
yeah if they go out there they're gonna
be successful and build up
and people are gonna be attracted to
that but there's no reason yet you can't
have
la austin new york as far as comedy goes
yeah and they're in the middle
remember texas a long time ago was a
[ __ ] beast for comics man
some great economists nashville
nashville is not far behind
and nashville's so low centrally located
that you can
compared to being all the way west and
when you're in nashville
it it's an hour and a half flight as
opposed to a six-hour flight you know so
if you're going to florida
okay if you're going to anywhere if you
want to kentucky if you're going to all
these different places new york's what
probably three hours from there
that's not bad no new york is uh an hour
and a half no
not from nashville look like no wait
dude nashville's southeast and then
[ __ ] new york
has to be three i bet two to three hour
flight three hours
let me see what is it two and a half two
and a half two but really two hours and
fifteen minutes two hours two hours and
fifteen
it's not bad yeah compared to like the
six hours that you're you know
that's like going from here to colorado
yeah
so it's a little bit i don't know i
don't know but
but nashville's popping because you got
theo out there now yeah nate bargaski
yeah they do something josh every monday
every monday yeah yeah yeah i'm doing a
yeah i'm doing it i'll be there march
3rd i'm doing a live podcast with steve
burns yeah that's why oh hell yeah
yeah big and hard baby big and hungry
nothing big or hungry about it nope
every monday big an honor
it's fun does steve have a nickname he
calls himself stevie cakes
wait what what yeah stevie cakes i i get
about that do you see it
trying to come up with we're trying to
come up with uh nicknames it's like i'm
the man dragon no he's you're not no i'm
the man the earth one
that's pretty scary watch i saw a game
with that
no i'm not into it dude bro that sounds
so bad
not a man dragging out yourself no [ __ ]
no
when the girl keeps trying to get some
like word to catch she's like
trying to check would you quit saying
fetch it's not gonna catch on drop it
yeah
oh yeah how about i send you
stop the stupid dragon stuff mandrake
you're you're the weathered worm or your
rings or your big gay out the grand mule
there's a great great meal he committed
to that [ __ ] bro
i'll give him that thank you you
committed bro you did it three times and
it got
you know the the got deeper held it but
i think it
could help you know it is a little
different you know
donkey would have left you like no
[ __ ] man dragon not into it sam
tripley calls himself the fat dragon the
bad dragon
he's not even fat yeah he doesn't shake
he's he's
sam sam will tell you that he's
yeah he's got some yeah he's built like
a lieutenant at a fire station
you know like he's retired he's got a
thin face
why does he call himself the fat dragon
hey dude how about this
i think we may have to go on conspiracy
social club where we talk about
conspiracies
i think we have to jump over to a
different platform like
rockfin because then leave patreon well
because
vimeo if you talk sam was talking about
he was disparaging
this is [ __ ] so crazy this is like
weird sam was
not gonna [ __ ] up our show by talking
about this are you no all right sam is
disparaging
a political figure okay who my andrew
cuomo
okay and we got kicked off that that we
got kicked off vimeo
because you can't spread misinformation
i debunked the conspiracies right so he
comes up with a conspiracy and
he brings it to the bunker right and
what's he saying about andrew and his
brother
well he was he was taking an extreme
view on
on when andrew cuomo sent covet positive
patience
back to the nursing home got it to
flatten the curve what i was saying is
that
he wasn't trying to murder people but he
was trying it was a political thing
he looked good managing correct and and
it wasn't in his interest to have a
bunch of people died well no he's gonna
run involved he's getting recalled now
yeah like why would he want right he's
gonna lose his job
right his his approval ratings but sam
had a different take on it
and meaning that that he's a sociopath
and all that
when you do that vimeo goes you are
you're talking conspiracy but that's an
opinion that's the show
yeah that's not that's something we got
taken but but people can't
watch flip conspiracy social club so i
gotta go over to at all
no they took if you're if you're talking
conspiracy so video
right vimeo has a thing where you can't
talk conspiracy even though i'm
debunking it vimeo it said you cannot
someone reach out to him go you know the
show is one guy spits conspiracies the
other guy argues against us doesn't
matter that's what he tries
to do that but what they do is they just
say you violated this terms
no and patreon's on venmo so yeah so if
you're on patreon they use vimeo as
their video people like to watch their
podcasts
yeah so now do you know that you got to
go over here you signed up for it
yeah i did the whole thing now now like
people i don't know
i didn't know about them yeah that's
censoring i didn't know that yeah i
didn't know i don't know that so patreon
this must be a new thing right because
behind the paywall
doesn't matter bubba it doesn't matter
they have their policy
that's that's insane but but this is
what happened at freedom of speech it
doesn't exist
you you have so as long as the narrative
fits whatever they believe in
you can do this the new york times
what's her name uh uh stacey abrams i
think
she tweeted she just tweeted that the
democrats um
wrote a letter demanding what uh
demanding what comcast a t all these
huge cares are going to do about fox
news's spread of misinformation
what about the left that's that's that's
their narrative both of us are
foolish there's been so we're dealing
now with
with with the power structures idea of
what
misinformation is what they deem yeah
conspiracy
and so if you say you cannot say you
cannot say
if you better if you're on youtube right
you cannot say that masks
don't work if you say i don't think
masters are effective
you are you are in youtube we're not
saying that yeah we're not saying that
i'm not saying
we all just went we're not saying that
yeah in america
well you know uh it was either on
kingston or this i said
we were roasting somebody and i said you
look like a proud and you know they
pulled the entire video there you go
really for the proud
reference so all tripoli said was he's a
sociopath well tripoli
well okay to be inspired goes crazy with
conspiracy
that's what's happening i'm not a
conspiracy theorist i just think a lot
of them are
are actually destructive i don't i don't
agree with them and i know a lot of
people do
but for me i think it's important to
push back on conspiracies because a lot
of these conspiracy theories and i'm not
talking about sam here
sam's one of the nicest best people i
know great but a lot of conspiracy
theories whether people know it or not
have their roots in old-school
anti-semitism
it goes back to the nazi era it just
does yeah i mean they
say what you will but at the end of the
day when you start talking about the
rothschilds and all these bankers
they're all jewish bankers you're what
you're doing is spreading
you know and i also am pro i believe in
vaccines
i i study a little history and when you
have these
massive it is a problem when you have
like russian
and chinese you know elements trying to
spread this information about vaccines
and then you get in there a lot of
people are very distressful it works
so i i i understand that big tech has a
lot of
issues the the worry for big tech is
that when you do have real
misinformation
and it starts gaining traction and it
can get people killed
like it did in with the rohingya and
different countries
yeah you watch so the social dilemma
that's a real [ __ ] problem
that's a real problem but that
misinformation it also did with covert
right like some people didn't take you
serious
at all ended up dying no but a lot of
doctors
a lot of the doctors who were saying
look we're on the front lines
the stats you're hearing are not
consistent with the stats
we are seeing the stats we are seeing
are lower they got pulled
but but here's what i'm pulled for but
here's what else you know cnn won't let
the brothers interview each other they
he he's
prevented lee he they won't allow him to
interview his brother about any of this
personally i like seeing those guys
talk and i and i know i knew chris i
like seeing them too
i liked chris chris i believe chris
cuomo like he gets a lot of flack for
being a liberal
if chris cuomo was from my experience
and also know people are still in touch
with them
if chris was here hanging out or we were
out you he's a
he's a guy he's not a he's a he's a very
reasonable thoughtful guy he's not he's
full of [ __ ] on cnn though but so so is
the fox guys
yeah to me it's almost a character but
because they have to think because
they have to because they get paid they
can't tell they get told what to say
their ratings depend on it's not their
echo chamber they have right yeah they
have writers
it's not like of course they just read
off the monitor yeah and then they put
their input in and he's obviously
you know far left so these [ __ ]
don't even necessarily believe it
um not all there's no way they believe
all of it i think that you'd you know i
think someone
but i think though to back to them
pulling like
what's fake news and all that and they
don't want miss information spreading
i think the media and especially the
news i don't know how it is in the rest
of the country
but especially here in la like i know
for and cdc is going to release this
so they're saying oh you know there's
the brazilian strain there's the african
strain
it's much more deadly the cdc came out
went that's their
that's what that's their take on it yeah
we gave them this information where
yeah it might be more uh contagious but
it's not nowhere near as deadly
that's not true but the noose takes it
to scare you well the
world health organization also drives a
lot of cdc said was like no no
you guys took what we sent you one way
and you're running with it yeah so
here's the fact okay so then what yeah
what's your guys sources of
you know where do you get yeah where do
you get your news then
it's not fox and cnn you can be listen
to fox and cnn you can do that and you
can
you can listen to it with a grain of
salt and just understand that depending
on who you're listening to on those
news organizations that they are as much
opinion makers their opinion they're
they're
so so they have an agenda they have an
agenda they're speaking to a
to their echo chamber so tucker
carlson's speaking to people that
already agree
with him and already have a preconceived
they doubled down the world championship
yeah and they
died on that hill yeah and then so laura
ingram that's the angle now if you go
over
you know to cnn or cn um rachel maddow
she's going to be speaking to people who
have who lean left but they're also
so see that's what makes it but cnn's
like here
fox is here and then you can listen to
both and come here
yeah like the beast bbc npr bbc abc's
great yeah
there's a lot of like some news
organizations try to be super neutral
about things
but you have to always listen to how
they're phrasing things because it's
very hard
you know i'm telling you i'm not i guess
i'm about to release this this uh did i
tell you about this i'm about to release
this
this interview tomorrow with a guy named
aleister bostwick yep
aleister bostwick i sent you that thing
on he said he had that youtube thing on
what crystalia should have done yeah and
he also has another thing on on
information we could have used yesterday
and he also has a video on on the truth
about woody allen and
and his house his documentary you can
see that no but you got to see what no
he's a real journalist alex aleister
bostwick is a real journalist okay and
he went and looked at
all the stuff like with mia farrow and
like
you know what really happened three of
her three of her eleven children
uh three of her 10 adopted children
committed suicide um
there was there was apparently and he
has the courtroom transcripts
they offered willie allen eight eight if
he gave
them eight million dollars um you know
to shut to to they would shut up they
wouldn't make it a scene and woody allen
was like no
i'm taking a lie detector and she
wouldn't take a lie let watch the video
but anyway i did an interview with him
i'm gonna release it tomorrow i don't
know what i'm gonna release it on but
yeah
yeah i i said i forgot what you're yeah
cause i do want to watch it oh it's
graham can't
i'll release it on youtube okay based on
my channel whatever yeah and i'll i'll
post it
brian yeah i'll post it on my instagram
i got you i know we're fine so he's a
he's a lib he worked for liberal
corporation he worked for
um he worked for uh buzzfeed he worked
for
huffington post now he works for verizon
okay and he's
essentially a freelance guy but he's
really
he just tries to just he's a [ __ ]
thorough journalist and i said
if i were to say to you um if you were
to say
look you you're at the huffington post
very very liberal and very anti-trump
right and if you were to say let me find
one good thing about trump like let me
find
one good thing that might have been good
for the economy let's say his
deregulation policy
and he said it would get greenlit
however
however would it be promoted would it be
on the front page
no right and then what would happen to
me when i come back to work
the next day and the week after are you
going to want to come to work
every day and have people cutting their
eyes at you all the time
like that yeah and then they start
talking about you on the chat boards
like they did to uh barry what's her
name barry weiss new york times
yeah super liberal but she was like this
is getting crazy guys this is an
ideology and we're not even reporting
the news objectively
they started talking about on a chat
board it got so hostile for her that she
had
well he said what happens in the
situation what happens is you go over to
you over
you go over to breitbart or the daily
wire because you can't
you don't know yeah so you so we get so
journalists get pushed
in one team or another you just you
can't help but get pushed in one
direction or another otherwise you're a
pariah at your own work
that's a problem so i i anyway it was a
good interview because he's he's
somebody i respected he's a young guy
yeah we found him because of the chris
stuff right yeah you and i were sending
that to each other yeah
i'm like for sure send this watch this
woody allen thing he did [ __ ] yeah
but yeah but that's what makes it tough
because like yeah like i mean
i never watched the [ __ ] news based
off of like just like you said like
fox is over here you know it's seeing it
it's just i don't know it's just such a
wild world
world and then like to pick a side you
know i don't know it's just it's just
two which side is brian williams on the
11th hour which side would be brian
williams is pretty he's just pretty
vanilla
yeah he makes a lot of money because
he's not threatening not threatening
but would you have to take a side to far
left before right it's like brian he's
jesus because that's why
he for me or no i'm just saying like
from brian williams yeah out of all the
guys i
mean yeah oh so this is vanilla ice
cream yeah okay
i mean i think also to keep in mind like
you know it's like are you left are you
right or admit
give me the give me the issue give me
the topic immigration yeah
i don't know it's really complicated i
don't want to see kids in cages
i know that we all agree with that but
at the same time i don't think we should
have ever
i think borders are reasonable and they
mean something if they don't then then
take the front door off your house you
gotta have some regular i mean so so how
do we do it it's not easy when
latin america is a disaster when you've
got guatemala el salvador and you've got
desperate people coming
and you're you're a border agent and
you're dealing with children who've been
in the desert and they're dehydrated or
maybe dying
and you're dealing with all this [ __ ]
and you're finding people who are dead
that shit's all you're doing is you're
not even political at that point you're
just trying to make the world a better
place you're just trying to deal with
all the [ __ ]
you see you're part of an organization
called ice people saying you're bad
well bro i'm just i'm just trying to i'm
trying i have a job to do i'm trying to
you know it's really the incentive
structure that causes people
but also with the with like immigration
stuff like the rules are almost for the
the exception so it's like when we ran
syria when all the syrians left
and germany was like yeah we'll take
them it's tough because you're gonna get
those
those outliers those guys who are still
involved in nice it can't just be that
easy as well france goes we'll take them
and then they have all these issues yeah
but again those guys are the exception
majority of the people that come over
there are going to contribute to society
and be good people yeah but the that
exception will scare
everybody and keep them out you get like
young man it's like it's it's it's like
it's like you know
like real italians [ __ ] hate the
godfather
good fellas yeah because it paints all
like you mean italian
mafia yeah like that's how my grandpa.1
italians are in the mafia they [ __ ]
hate it dude
so same with like muslims like oh isis
are you kidding me dude
how many muslims are in the world you
know you're in isis 0.0001
but they get labeled
i think 10 of our medical uh doctors and
staff are
muslim in this country you know if
you're iranian or you're
you know from that you know you come
here or whatever and you're muslim
you go to school your parents are like
oh you're going to be a doctor or
you've got a couple choices yeah yeah
you got to get six degrees yep
it's the same thing you know how many
italian irish what's that you're italian
irish italian irish that's why i have
that's why i [ __ ] i grew up all over
the world right yeah i did
oh let me
of you yeah you've always like damn yeah
i'm i'm building it i'm a gazelle
no run it's also been built the same way
for
hollywood listen look at that that's
ectomorph
dude how funny was that man i know i
took myself also
dude how about how about the post dilly
okay hey how about the post dalia sent
this
that was at the comedy store i'm trying
to do a video looks like
that's the live factory factory oh that
factory yeah yeah you don't remember
that
um
[Laughter]
that 10-minute podcast picture is
[ __ ] you took your shirt off lb you
know how
you i was watching jack dawg i was
watching the other day
on uh youtube when sasso came out firing
the kid
and was redoing montel jordan
[Applause]
he's just he's one of the funniest have
you talked to him
yeah i talked to him periodically but
he's all heidi heidi because of kobe
kobe oh yeah
the guy big guy big guy so i think he's
a little worried about it all the big
guys are
yeah like but all my big friends are
like he won't hang with me because i
travel
you know and he's like now you're on the
road so we're not getting him on the
show for quite something
yeah he's gotta get vaccinated but he's
uh
he's been a lot like he's some people
are so funny naturally like they're just
so impossibly talented
i've said that to him before i go i
think you're the greatest
impressionist i've ever i've ever seen
in my life and how how did this show do
i don't see it it got cancelled yeah oh
the one on nbc well if you want to play
that game if you want to be on
mainstream tv yeah you pilots get yeah
don't get picked up
or how about i think kevin james taking
all his jobs you know well kevin james
is something else but even that even
that's hard
well he's on netflix now yeah but i mean
how many people are watching
it's always i don't know tv has just
changed so much this whole business has
changed
drastically if you're going to put all
your eggs in a netflix show
now hold on so so new media
podcasting stand up we're all very lucky
because if you're doing a netflix show
you're going to do eight episodes
10 episodes and a lot of times that
contract keeps you from doing it you
can't do anything else
so that so you shot so how long does it
take to do 10 episodes i'm gonna i'll
give it i'll give it
three months give it yeah maybe okay
i'll give it three months so now you got
now you got nine more months to
right you have to figure it out what are
you going to do you don't have a podcast
you can't
pay your mortgage on that i'm not paying
you that much
i'm saying in l.a yeah james can yeah if
you're kevin james yeah but if you're
just a person on there no
if you're if you're fourth lead yeah
supportive yeah you need something more
by the way speaking of acting yeah you
saw oh you saw it you saw that
oh yeah yeah yeah what's that it was
good took my words i liked it what was
it yeah
oh yeah yeah wait so was it a commercial
for xbox
or otterbox because i saw both well
here's the thing uh it was a collab
oh okay but but it was more xbox i have
three more is it on tv
a fan tagged me uh i reposted it is it
on youtube or no
it's on you we put on youtube it's on
youtube have you posted to your social
media
yeah yeah i'm getting a lot of positive
reviews uh we have i'm shooting another
one in march
look at that right there now we can
critique going on
i was actually really good i was much
smaller back then look at that posture
i like it look at that look at that
look at the walk look at that look yeah
the focus
now do you have any speaking lines oh
okay we'll get to that
yeah look at that look at the handle
okay
this is the girl i was telling you about
how can we get you to stare at your
phone more
you play xbox on your video on your
phone now that's so dope
oh damn calm down yeah now here this is
my line watch okay where do you talk
[Music]
now where where's your lines at yeah
look what look what brian
brian
i'm glad you took my acting workshop i
take credit for this commercial now
why well because because because what i
just feel like
i did i'm sorry did i talk when he spoke
did i miss the
what were your lines my line was game
connected
better did i was that in there it was
think about hollywood think about
hollywood it's not about the lines about
the intention thank you
thank you b you saw you saw my face you
saw them
now i don't want to say anybody could do
that but wow three more they chose me
you smile they smile
i have a great smile i believed you no
they chose you for sure i mean you're
chosen
i had an acting teacher i was doing a
scene one time in acting class from a
bunch of people i didn't know and i'm
doing this heavy
trying to [ __ ] and i just hear the
teacher go i don't believe you
[Laughter]
i believe you i believe you on the third
dragon have you ever taken uh acting
classes yeah i did for like three years
how'd it go i liked it i i i think
acting classes are dope
i hated mine you hated him yeah didn't
like him mr pettigrew he was so hard on
me
once you go somewhere else there's
thousands well because he said if you
quit now
you're gonna quit in life and that stuck
with me yeah but you could just go to
another acting coach
you're not necessarily not necessarily
just leaving he just wasn't the
teacher's supposed to be hard on you
sometimes yeah
because you you get caught in your
little tricks he taught me how to cry on
uh on the spot that's the guy who like
he was like i want to see better but the
other thing
if you're an acting coach think how much
[ __ ] riff raff you deal with
in your class oh nobody oh so much most
people aren't going to make it
this girl is from nebraska she's
homecoming queen teaching me the next
[ __ ] you know big thing but acting
teachers that never made it though
if you really look at it but there are
some great teachers who
those who can't coach yeah some of them
are amazing though like so
a lot of times they're trying to get you
out of your own way what do you know
jeffrey
oh [ __ ] he had an acting coach
yeah for years oh wow can you can you
get him with me one of the greatest
he's one of the greatest he does he's
acting he's one of the great actors
i mean ever i put him up against anybody
and he was one of the greatest teachers
that [ __ ] was psychic
that dude would look back and go like
this he would go he'd go
what's going on and you'd be like huh he
goes you want the good news you want the
bad news
and there's good news first
good good news is you got one foot out
in one foot in
bad news you got one foot out right what
happened think about quitting now
people start crying how about this how
about this
my favorite is this guy's doing scene
and he goes
after the scene we'd all be waiting to
see what he's gonna say i need to go
what's going on with your right leg you
gotta go what
he is your right leg what's going on so
you're so protected that leg and that's
i just see you kind of your whole body's
leaning in that direction guy goes
nothing i don't know
nothing nothing's going on with your
right leg guy goes i mean
he's you don't see that walk for a sec
walk
i'd be like and go yeah see and he goes
well i mean yeah i mean nothing ever
happened he goes i mean i was in the
crocs and i broke my femur in half yeah
so i had well it's
the [ __ ] could pick up on that
kind of stuff beast it just ain't just
you dude a student of human behavior
yeah and then he would sometimes show
you how to do something
and and like like you'd do a scene and
you'd work on it and or
my favorite of this he'd go watch this
you go how long did you work on the
scene
so tell me like tell me tell me 12 hours
hold on
12 hours three hours maybe
and i'm being generous so what's going
on
you don't want to you don't want to do
this i've seen it all man you've seen it
all yeah
but he's still he's still not doing it
is he no he stopped teaching
2002 yeah he's blown up yeah i think
he's what's funny i was talking to
chapelle about this is
agents trying to adapt to you know now
there's podcasts and stand up
yeah youtube you can there's all these
different digital apps
and they're trying to keep up and then
they throw you tv ideas and you're like
let's go through this if i get that tv
show so i'm shooting you say monday
through friday
well you know i have a podcast monday
through thursdays the only day
well that's now i do the i have no every
day i podcast
so if you if i if you have to take that
away then
how much is a conversation yeah but and
i will just think about the long play
i own these podcasts so you want me to
do this tv show and shut down all this
for
for how long and you'll work for 16
hours a day please yeah
yeah and what i mean by that is you'll
be in makeup waiting but it's it's funny
to watch
it's funny to watch them juggle what do
you mean agents
yeah just because they it's just i'm
like how much pain you know i make that
in a day doing this like
yeah i know but that's podcast i'm like
i'm sorry so is that less than
this tv network mm-hmm you're getting if
you have if you want thousand people
if you want fame have a successful
podcast it's gonna
people are gonna know you a lot more
than what oh 100 but also think about it
like when's the like how much do you
know about leonardo dicaprio
i don't know i don't know anything you
ever heard my long form podcast
how much you know about joe rogan or
brian callan or yeah tim dillon or chris
delete
andrew was andrew schultz doing a
shitload of tv before this no he made it
no he was he was on tv
but he people know him from 100 percent
from his just being
so amazing on social media and being
like we go and that's adapting in 2021
these celebrities now who are
untouchable and there's there's a few at
the pinnacle
but outside that no one gives a [ __ ]
about the rest of them yeah there's like
this elite like
10. name name the last in the past three
years and i'll wait
this is true who yeah who who were the
uh give me a couple names of of
actual oscar winners it used to be they
were household names
who won an oscar last year well that's
just just really
uh supporting yeah that brad pitt we
know because we've known him
yeah it's brad yeah but we don't actors
are no longer what they were because
it's so atomized yeah they just there's
people is you got you're competing with
youtube podcasts
stand up so many everything so so an
actor no longer can capture
you know the imagine the collective
imagination how many people have seen
the movie how many
moonlight won an oscar okay that's a
movie name one actor from it
uh trevante rose i was in the film with
him marshay ali
um well it's an all black cast yes in
black guys yeah but yeah
why are you playing
yeah most people would not know that
yeah not enough it's just it's just
what it's just the narratives changed
the media has changed
but meanwhile i i do love the world of
acting i think it's such an
amazing like thing like just to see
someone portray something and like one
of my favorite actors
yeah one of my favorite actors is val
kilmer i love val kilmer you know i
think he's [ __ ]
great he's great and uh you know just to
watch him like
portray something like and you no longer
see
val kilmer i think i don't know i just
think it's badass right now
he's your favorite actor one of my
favorites
he hasn't worked in a long time no he
has a yeah there's not a lot of weight
over the throat issues
yeah he was great in the 90s he yeah he
was that was uh he's
he's my favorite movie yeah [ __ ]
dinero
oh my god
oh my god yep you know oh when they
first like yeah that i think i was like
1992. he's probably 96.
really yeah i think he's a little
ninety-five ninety-five five
yeah wow still holds up sure does
we had to do a monologue uh great movie
in that scene yeah you had to do that
you had to do that
yeah they said that yeah in the
monologue they initially sit down
together
that's that's the shooting scene yes
celebrities all different now isn't it
because you got
like when i was at zoo gym uh the owner
introduced me to this tick tocker
i think much of it and then uh
he just popped up on my youtube feed and
he has like i don't know like a hundred
million followers
you know his name no no clue i don't
know yeah 100 million yeah he's like
talkers are the modern superstars now
he's so rich tick tockers yeah tick
tockers
yeah they're like they're talking about
my daughter she's 12 and she's just like
everyone's obsessed
yeah but it's all niche right like that
guy not even really that
big of a niche these kids have like 30
million followers on it it's still niche
though
because that kid could get coffee no one
knows who he is like leonardo dicaprio
can't the age of the big star
is not there also a hundred million
followers that last how long does it
last
how much how much talent do they
actually really have and a hundred
million followers on instagram doesn't
mean that 100 million people in the
world can equate yeah yeah
yeah to the point that social media
isn't real they say one in 10 people are
on social media when we walk down the
street
so if that kid gets coffee they don't
know who he is yeah
but also also you're you did it in
30-second bursts
there's it's a little bit different of a
skill set i think you know it's not that
they're not talented it's just
you got to succeed it's just a different
skill yeah your audience is 12 year olds
too
tick tock is a young audience that's
very fickle they'll just go on to the
next thing
yeah let's go some current events what
do you got jen
first one okay so this is an update to a
story that we did a few days ago
about a potential meek mill lyric
talking about
going out on a chopper and he refers to
kobe bryant
uh vanessa bryant actually saw this and
she reacted
uh yeah she she asks people don't post
like tributes to kobe either
yeah she doesn't like having to see
tributes of
her daughter and which is kind of weird
my husband you know yeah
it's just triggering for her so she'd
rather not stay off social media though
yeah i'm sure she does you can also just
stay off of it
you know like your your husband was a a
legend and so many people respect them
you pay tribute to them i'm sure there
are ways where like she can't avoid
certain things so i'm sure there are
people like in her ear showing her like
hey did you see
what meek mill did even if she's trying
to stay off social media yeah
like word gets around you can stay off
of it though you know
demand that society doesn't post
tributes is a little
that's crazy it's insane but also with
with meek mill somewhere
you know the meek mill didn't release
this song no he wasn't going to release
it and it got leaked yeah
him because he was with a little baby
yeah so he got leaked so this was never
supposed to be out
yeah what's your favorite meek mill
that's probably that one and
i said don't i hate that line though
because i had it bleeped out
yeah oh you had that line but apparently
he had a conversation with uh
vanessa bryant behind the scenes wait
hold on sorry
you said what my rap has to be tactful
and respectful
who's your favorite rapper my favorite
light rapper
michael moore put us on game bryant matt
macklemore is [ __ ]
white i mean not that i noticed but i've
heard
hey remember he sent me that white
rapper i went two things
don't ever send me a white rapper in a
video ever again well i watched
the travis scott yeah yeah
yeah and i kept wanting to see what made
him great
like because i i like to so his come up
story's great yeah but what i was
looking at like with kanye
i went and listened to other musicians
explain to me why he's original
right i don't know music jeff scott so
what i'd like you to do is i want you to
show me how to
like compare what i noticed about the
con the concerts travis scott it was
very interesting because it was like a
throw it was a combination of rap
and also the mosh pits of the [ __ ]
90s with that hardcore
yes rock [ __ ] so i was like oh this is
this is very interesting because he's
bringing black and white
kids together and they're [ __ ]
fanatical and it's an event
he's just like a spearhead of uh how
great is it how great it how great is in
that documentary when he go
he's not big he goes to astro world and
there's like 10 people in the crowd
and then he goes back a year later and
it's like it's sold out
so what what one of the best
performances he's just
is it personality or is it talent nice
no he's ball
he's super talented like he changed the
game as far as rap goes
his house
and then his fashion they collab with
jordan and nike and
mcdonald's mcdonald's like he's huge
huge yeah he's a huge playstation
dude i always say that success like that
is not an accident no
you're not you're not [ __ ] successful
like that you you're
when you meet people like that they're
smart as [ __ ] you get confused
by the style by by the packaging
sometimes you know
like he's where uh you know whatever
he's he seems like he's smoking a lot of
weed
and he's kind of just hanging out no no
he's all he's probably always thinking
he's always he's traveling he's probably
got he's the original yeah
y'all know if you've got straight a's
let's calm down a little bit surprised
by that yeah i didn't get straight lil
wayne did it well here's the no
watch out for the grey mule games oh
my belt like you guys yeah yellow pack
it in
packaging
that's a donkey but [ __ ] it oh whatever
and think about lights go down there you
go get ready to pack it in
and the lights go dark in here
shout out to the [ __ ] shout out to
the man dragon slash weather forum slash
and then i just [ __ ] come running out
abs from zero
dark daddy for days for days i got a
shirt like this one of those
shirts
yeah and then that's the chromosome
you're into it yeah and then he's behind
me for no reason
running behind me holding onto my hips
going yeah and you push me into the mind
no that then when you fall and your big
dick goes flapping everywhere then i
grab you by your
heel just your socks and pull you back
you're just going
hey
yeah yeah no you're on the concert stage
i'm pulling it's going uh yeah but i'm
gonna get a i'm gonna get some kind of
an infection
like i'm gonna get an infection on my
dick a dope concert
okay so there is a brand new
uh pakistani armed police police unit
that is gonna get trained
in skating around trying to prevent
theft
and street harassment i feel like it'd
be easy to knock those guys down
but this is footage of their training
dude nice skates
yeah this is awesome but just get on
horses though you know oh well no
they can't they're not even great
they're all scared
they're all a lot of pakistani oh wow
nothing looks softer than cops on skates
yeah how do you yeah how do you
that looks super unsteady and you're not
gonna be able to shoot straight the only
thing no there's no way yeah the only
thing to make this more gay if they had
cut off jean shorts on
they're not going to look like reno uh
i'm not going fast at all
they're getting in formation yeah this
is a terrible idea
that is okay on and they're not great at
skating either [ __ ]
they're not going to scare you you know
easy to get away from them and then what
are they going to do once they catch a
guy
and about a year they're going to start
getting real good though yeah they're
training right now but i get it yeah
watch this what happened jump
[Laughter]
[Applause]
though he's all scared he had to go to
the side he's all can any one of y'all
skate anyone
you can roll a blade skate yeah what
about you can you yeah come on
i can play it bro you could you could
blaze that's why you say it like that
let me say blake
i ride that line of balance just put it
that way you can shred
you can shred it do you go to atlanta
and go to cascade do you do that
watch out [ __ ] pakistan coming
coming through you don't see a lot of
skates on venice beach anymore sure
don't no i'm not very rare nah they're
very gay it's also very interesting that
it's very gay roller blades just
they went away skateboarding never went
away
you don't see rollerblades i was just in
santa monica
yeah but there might be one or two but
it's not popping like used to be like
that thing this is mean to say but when
you see a rollerblader a lot of times
you're like
i come i was like you i think you live
in your car
not to be but i mean thank you louie
it's just not hip anymore they're alone
and they're
they're dancing to music into that you
know they always have great bodies and
they're not
always great and you're like something's
wrong something happened yeah they're
usually thin
you know what i see a lot of is the
roller skates
that's what i see a lot of them i don't
see a lot of
there's not a lot of roller blading they
call it inline skating
right they're on rollerblades yeah polo
blazers in roller skates i see it all
the time
but more skateboarding why they went out
of focus for a reason
inline skates went out of fashion but
there was a reason there was something
like they just stopped people stopped
roller playing yeah it's a lot of deaths
i guess
why did inline skating die out but
skateboard bmx is still popping
yeah the death meal yeah and trick
oriented
oh it's a rated article though what was
that sport when women used to roll the
blade and they had
roller derby oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah mainly a lesbian sport let's call
it like another form of
outside i don't know
what about roller derby
[Laughter]
like in the preview they're always like
oh yeah yeah she's the
they're all built like us no they're
bigger bigger girls
on skates it's like a fast one for a guy
who likes muscular girls
you you like that yeah you get down with
a roller derby girl
i i appreciate every video i appreciate
muscles and tattoos on a woman i do what
what what and a big day okay so
uh the city of winnipeg is currently
snowing and they're having an
issue with people creating sexually
suggestive snowmen
throughout the city to the point where
they have city
they have city officials going by like
local parks and areas and knocking them
down
i'm not gonna lie hey that thing curvy
there's not a lot to do in winnipeg
uh-huh so in the wintertime
come on that thing that's fantastic
did you see that i wonder what that
one's did you did you see the tic-tock
thing that went viral where uh there was
a tick tock narrative that
uh the government created oh yeah that's
the an experiment
texas wait what they think oh yeah they
think yeah
there's a lot of videos of people trying
to burn the snow it doesn't melt
it doesn't yeah for whatever reason
there are a few videos one
is that they say it'll the snow will
turn black
which shouldn't happen because it's
supposed to be water and melt
yeah i know these [ __ ] tick tock
listen to me i was there
i was there for the three days it was it
started snowing yeah i was there
it was everywhere and it was this thing
no they say it's no they they think it's
snow but they think it's uh
like a artificial snow like snow
basically they think of the government
put it there well okay
because it was coming down from
everywhere in the sky yeah
this is a video right here someone said
do with a blow dryer
plugged in go get snow
go find some
not snow snowball here we go
highest setting hot
you have the one where the person set it
on fire cat oh yeah there's one that put
it in the microwave
that sets it on fire it still doesn't
melt i don't know if it's in this
article yeah that's it right there
how do i put this dope track on it but
oh no this is a tick-tock track
it's one of those that goes viral yeah
see it won't melt
it just turns black yeah i was oh it was
there
it's snow it's snow it's weird though it
is yeah it is weird
what's that one right this one because
there's government snow right here
just falls off your hand don't even make
it wet that's
yeah i love it what's this thank you
bill gates oh this is the light one
thank you bill gates this can trick us
that this is real
trying to trick us you'll see that's so
texas milton
and it's going to burn snow don't burn
snow [ __ ] melts no water no dripping
no nothing
that's crazy if i put this [ __ ] in the
microwave it's going to start sparking
because there's metal oh yeah prove it
they put it in a bible they did
no melting that's what was saying it is
weird it doesn't matter right b
yeah it gets weird what do you think i
don't know what you think i want to see
what sam
yeah snowed in texas i was there
yeah and it was everywhere i was sliding
around on my car so
if they have a plane that big and they
were able to cover all of texas and kill
all those animals
okay but it was freezing it was
uh i believe you but that those videos
are kind of crazy yeah the tick tock
videos i guess yeah
what do you mean i mean
it's so nuts that's the one i saw that's
ohio though
that's ohio never mind oh they're saying
it's fake too they
all can't be fake you want to watch it
though or no that's not i don't need to
watch it i don't need to watch it yeah i
mean
that's weird the government bill gates i
guess is the one
all right yeah and she's like thank you
bill gates when you start blaming if
she's all nice
that much yeah if you think the
government can create a snowstorm like
that it's just incredible
it is strange okay but that's what we
have conspiracy theories
yeah yeah man this is the topic yeah
yeah what else you got jen um
this one right here andrew schultz
i had to uh screen record it cat caught
this on andrew schultz's instagram
but uh he called out brian first he said
hey the boys are back which is cool
swim you're live you know what you're
and then here he says he's coming for
you brian
you're going to come with more speed mr
schultz i saw that
yeah he i told him and i said to him i
said i need more reach from you
you're fighting like frasier and i
stopped doing being inside fire let me
see
schultz on the wave there using your
reach i got a video oh he kills it right
here
brian hidden patch y'all want to see it
you do shows kills it right here yeah he
surfs
oh this is dope you're a badass let's
see my video
any of y'all watch the patrice doc i
didn't watch it
it's great it's on camera yeah uh bill
burr
uh producer yeah yeah it's great i had a
conversation with that guy with me and
dove david patrice crazy yeah
there's yeah legends he's got he had
some profound thought i mean i remember
i looked at dove and i go he's kind of
profound and dog goes the man drops a
heavy
a heavy thought he drops a heavy thought
how's dove doing
the best but you know he's just a real
estate tycoon
he is yeah he's doing stand-up but yeah
tell david
i miss him man i mean i don't he's got a
kid now so he spends his time with his
child oh well she gotcha
you guys already know about tiger woods
yeah yeah it's his right leg he's all
bunched up so yeah his ankle and uh both
of his legs so he's cool
just one leg just his right leg they
said it was a compound fracture
yeah but this is what they said here oh
they said it was a com
commune no what that was it called
combinated or whatever fracture that
means it didn't do a full break
but it broke and it like splintered up
which is freaky did you see the card
though yeah
yeah they needed the jaws of life to get
them out really was it all coming
yesterday what what happened he just uh
was going too fast
oh that was just the regular video
what are you looking for chin just the
car oh [ __ ] that's a bentley
yeah yeah was i warming up with this
video or was i
was i hitting hard oh chin you guys i
opened
yeah but sometimes you get me whether
you're just warming up
because my speed is blinding so you see
you
accepting his challenge this is okay man
yeah yeah [ __ ] insane
i mean especially after that crazy yeah
[ __ ]
i know and he was just driving by
himself and he just he said no drugs
right
he rolled and apparently where did it go
good god man
that's so scary to me
there was this uh video on instagram
about this guy who was you said it again
malik
this when you see this this semi hit
this this car
and it had a dash cam it just slid off
boom and just
[ __ ] but i guess they were okay these
crumple zones are incredible where
where where the passenger sta stays safe
and everything else just crumples around
it
look at that mm-hmm both sides just
broke off let's see what we got
okay so you challenged i don't know
andrews
we let me do the right hand and i'm
gonna do a left hand okay fine
all right so one two three
let me do it on the camera
you look young right here
this is this is pre uh this is 2019.
2019.
man my son's a good camera did you get
all that uh i got a lot of it
we saw nothing there please all right
what else do you have chin
i apologize that was an awful video
but don't ever send that again you guys
are talking about
the uh dark web and child pornography
yeah do you hear about travis fulton one
of the
like legendary mma fighters he had like
over three hundred years the most right
ever in history he is now indicted on
child porn
pornography [ __ ] i don't remember travis
he was like a like a judgement like a
weird legitimate journeyman yeah he
fought
everybody wow so he
says he tried to persuade a minor under
the age of 18 to
engage in sexually explicit content with
his camera and then he also
possess child pornography of a minor
under 12.
piece of [ __ ] man damn yeah
so there you go not good and then you
can see here he also has like a
charge on him too for beating up a girl
he's always like underground famous like
he wasn't like a well-known guy
he's got a charge on beating up a girl i
don't know i i mean i know of him but
never
never met him anything yeah the most
he fought once in the ufc like 98 or
some [ __ ]
there he goes 320 fight resume yeah
that's insane
that's not a journey man that's an iron
man they should be fine in jail
i don't know nope piece of [ __ ] though
yeah they uh i thought this was
fascinating
this was brought up on a different show
but have you seen dr carl hart on joe
rogan's podcast before
this guy yeah i've watched his ted talk
yeah so he's a very smart guy very well
spoken a neuroscientist he
he grew up i think what in miami i'm not
sure where he grew up but he does
he admitted that he snorts heroin from
time to time at night
yeah well he says if you don't do it
with a
sedative so if you mix heroin with
alcohol you got problems
if you snort heroin on its own what he
says is that
it the idea that you can do you do
heroin you're addicted for life or you
smoke crack once you're addicted is
completely [ __ ]
in fact yeah in fact if like you know
with mice that comes from a study with
mice where they are different animals
different animals i think even primates
where they give you the the animal
cocaine and the animal kept hitting the
letter
lever until it died until it did so much
cocaine and died however
when they give gave the mice or the
primates
um treats and receptive sexual partners
and activities to play they didn't they
went and did that instead
so the idea is that when you are a
person who has no other options
but drugs a lot of times that's what
creates the addiction
if you have a life and a full life
you're less likely to be taken by the
addiction you're more likely to be a
recreational drug user
than you are even with things like
heroin that's also from
his thesis yeah his perspective yeah
here's the other thing
yeah great dude the other thing is he
does these lines and talks about his
withdrawals for
12 to 16 hours that's a problem yeah
it's a problem
you know i don't think i he says
legalize all drugs which i actually i
agree with yeah
and he makes that argument i think
that's a central argument but um
you know it's it is still heroin yeah do
you have to do heroin every night
yeah that's [ __ ] scary he talks about
how good it is
when i don't do it i have major
withdrawals when you're my age and you
like
if i drink two glasses of wine and i eat
cheese
i get puffy but the thing is
but also like no one wants to go through
those withdrawals that's why they keep
doing it
exactly so i remember him talking on
rogan's podcast once about withdrawals
he's it's like
you have a flu right it's like a flu
it's awful i've had withdrawals before
when i was
i was picking up norco painkillers
because you know i was prescribed to it
and then when the refill came out or
wasn't there's no more left
i had crazy which i thought was dying
yeah yeah so i think for certain people
man like
if you still do kratom every day every
day yeah
and and uh how many do you take i don't
even know have you you'll see me kind of
like
what's up have you upped your dosage no
it's always been the same yeah same
doses
and i don't have withdrawals from kratom
oh do you you take no i mean i've read
it i've taken it
one day
what are your what are the things you
take what are the supplements you take
nicotine kratom nicotine
doesn't create them and nicotine kind of
nope not at all no
creatine nicotine uh no i don't take
creatine now i take nicotine
fish oil multivitamin that's what i do
that's it protein powders
yeah after a workout but what about so
so why create them
i just like the way it like like gets me
ready for the show
really it calms you down or what does it
do no i don't want to be calm for this
one so what is
that's weird but for me it calms me down
i'm like but there's different strands
of kratom there's different types of
creatures they are both oh yeah i don't
take the same [ __ ] no but they i take
all the different strands i don't feel
any difference from the different
strategies i do i do like one one i
won't feel anything if it's a real like
calming strand i won't feel anything on
it that's more of a red vein
how much whiskey can you drink before
you start feeling buzz because you're a
big boy
uh usually like four doubles
four doubles that meaning meaning two
two shots in each one so four shots
oh okay four shots and then you start
feeling yeah a little loosey
and what about how much would it take
for you to get drunk
i mean like if i'm doing that and i do
shots between the shows i'll be a little
buzzed
but i've never seen you drunk no never
no
that's that's yeah i gotta agree you
still a whiskey gentleman oh yeah
yeah my whiskey drops soon is it is it
everywhere every evening you're having
no not every night anymore i stopped
doing that because i went cold turkey in
january
i completely stopped in january i'd say
once a week now you never drink you know
how to sip
alcohol if i'm on the road i'll like i'm
in tampa this friday saturday
i'll drink for the shows do you still do
your wine do you dab and i just you know
i don't know if i told you this but i
couldn't figure out what the [ __ ] was
wrong with
why wine wasn't tasting good
wine [ __ ] stopped tasting like wine
after i had covered
i just realized that too i was like i'm
opening these bottles of wine i'm like
this doesn't taste good anymore like the
way it used to coffee's a little bit the
same way
it [ __ ] my taste i have to drink it
real strong i got some long-term
damage from in in terms of my taste buds
how's those lungs papa 100 i think it
might be better
yeah i took that steroid that inhalable
steroid i [ __ ]
always [ __ ] with your lungs in the
beginning i was i couldn't you know it
was
it hit my lungs and i was like he was
awesome he was like
sick sick i was saying i didn't feel
[ __ ] yeah
dragon when the dragon was down the man
dragon could still breathe fire i could
still send you
i want to thank everybody for making the
man dragon a thing guys yeah
now i feel like i'm just gonna always
say yeah i mean i appreciate it but um
it was a great thing
yeah yeah yeah but uh at the end of the
day it was it was humbling so no more
no more you were you were fine yeah i
was fine i'm not a pudding it's just i
said
i'm out of money i spent online i'm not
a [ __ ]
never tell you time we were shooting
this thing we had to get on a horse he's
never ridden a horse
and bringing you well yeah we there was
a scene where we were he was playing uh
indian he's playing a native american
i'm playing cowboy
i can look it up in there and uh oh
actually we got taken down last time we
played it oh really yeah they pulled our
[ __ ] damn
but we you know we had to ride there's a
big horse stun horse
and i can ride so i i was you know had
shots of me riding off and then coming
back
but brandon really never been on a horse
so brennan was like i was like it'd be
funny
if we fall off together but we have to
get started let's just send you a
picture
because it's a horse and it's riding so
if you fall off you have to be a stunt
man
so brennan goes why don't we just do it
and i go
because well because there's ground
there's i mean it's a shrubbery
so you're scared oh you mean you want to
fall together
off a horse that's running yeah and he
goes he goes yeah i go
no no no no because because we're not
some man we can get really hurt like
that and he goes
you're such a [ __ ] like he was dead
serious
i was like oh man i want to see it yeah
where can we see it
it's on vimeo they have like all of them
on vimeo i think
okay so but you don't have a picture
though dude yes yeah i do what are you
doing
now we spent the full day naked look at
that how are you
wait wait wait yeah we pulled david we
did naked and afraid that was
oh god we got it have you not seen
fighter in the kids 3d no no we haven't
seen i don't know
and you guys aren't fans i think it's
great personally
is it is it available yeah it's someone
has it on vmware i think it's the same
guy i think it was the director of
someone he has it on his channel
but i just can't play the sounds or
you've got it we'll show it really
let me see if i can search for it that
might be it right
yeah let me know if you see him here
i know these are freaking great i saw
that audition when uh
when brendan was a cop johnny knoxville
no it looks like i'm done that's the
great mitch rouse
oh [ __ ] will sass remember
this was y'all look so much younger back
then
that was a while ago dude that's
probably six seven years ago which i did
the ymca
re reshoot we did it there we are i'll
just show you
look how bright it goes
watch it but then we'll
oh dude that was how about that i look
back on that times one of the
greatest oh my god you don't realize it
when you're doing it
and you've never acted before and he
[ __ ] that was great yeah it was so
funny
i am man but i i posted this video
oh no it's just you know the cop the cop
cop yeah yeah that was
great so what it was just like y'all
just
doing different skits i think eight or
ten parts we would sit down at a table
like this yeah
me brian and mitch brennan and mitch and
just we would just
we'd be sitting there like this and then
something somebody would go like brenda
would be like this is a stupid idea but
and we go well it's not that stupid and
then it would just spark something yeah
and and i can honestly say that it was
equal parts all of us came up with ideas
like all of us
we beat game of thrones and amy
schumer's show on uh for most
more downloads on
they couldn't believe what where our
ratings were we're on on itunes
column brought us on then after us colin
coward had dane on
that's what me and dana were super
beefing and he goes i gotta bring up
brendan shot because
obviously a talented kid's a star like
don't you feel like you [ __ ] up the
relationship with her like
all the kids over here doing this isn't
he inspiring other fighters
and dana's like he's whatever and just
moved yeah what
but dude i mean that's thick of it that
was such a that was
that was different now how hard we were
laughing with will sasso
oh my god will will will was playing a
bully he was the guy who wouldn't
he wouldn't die we kept trying to kill
him and he wouldn't die
go to that one chin i want to watch some
bro
yeah i kind of wanted to do one more
will so [ __ ] funny
what was that why is it we did a video
video
how about that video where you're
dressed like a lion and i'm dressed like
a deer we did some weird [ __ ] okay so mr
bully
oh yeah he's amazing one second
i'm gonna mark this i miss this [ __ ]
it's a commercial for cologne the whole
time immortal bully
the new fragrance
it was a cologne
it's the longest worst commercial
the viewers and the listeners can't see
any of that i know
oh yeah oh well yes well they can they
just have to go to
just go to vimeo yeah yeah that was a
long one but it's naked
so wait do you guys get the rights to it
no dude
some of them some of them were just box
sports uh
you know paid for it so oh they paid oh
i thought y'all didn't know
yeah they they did the budget and then
once we had a certain number they got
their money back then we got a cut from
that oh everything was just improvised
everything was like what are we going to
do
how we're going to do this we gotta we
got to bury him we're just trying to
come up with
yeah it's dope are you it
yeah the one the dating one where you
have to find my
like if you in case you die we're
interviewing we had a bunch of like
improv guys where me and brian sit down
with them
in case joanna dies like who who's or in
case i die
do they get to replace me so we
interview all these improv guys dude
most of that we couldn't get through it
because i kept laughing oh because the
guys kept
well the actors mitch rouse brought all
the second city [ __ ]
oh yeah city hollywood those guys can
you probably shoot
that'll when we have time that that
that's that's my that might
that might be my favorite one so funny
it was so funny
they were so good brendan had never
really been around
those kind of those kind of i was
laughing so you're talking about guys in
their 40s and 50s who've been doing
improv their whole life they've been on
everything
every single day and you see them like
do stuff and like you just say oh
you're you're here and you're somebody
they're interviewing to be
a prospective candidate yeah this is how
they tell them yeah and they just go
and they sell themselves to me why they
should replace me it's so [ __ ] i mean
it's so good
i can't wait to watch it all yeah yeah
and so hard like
like they'd come up with [ __ ] and just
like that handshake the guy was doing
the handshake
yep he's like worm in the apple
where are you at this weekend brian uh
march four five and six i am in
jacksonville
uh at the comedy zone jacksonville
florida and then march 11 12 13 omaha
nebraska funny bone
and just added huntsville alabama march
26 27 20.
markets yeah have you been to the
huntsville i don't know where
it's at huntsville alabama and i heard
it's gonna stay that's that stardom
i'm not sure what it is so you stand up
like i don't know is this stand up live
does it stand up live at home huntsville
alabama is interesting because it's
where
nasa like you've been talking before
yeah and then i saw
that's the place i saw a guy with just
walking down the street with an a cave
like with a with an ar-15 stand up live
and shenanigans
oh thank goodness yeah which one are you
doing i'm stand up live stand up live
yeah it's a good club actually stand up
live uh
and then this weekend tampa florida
february 26 27th that's this friday and
saturday tampa florida
cleveland ohio uh hilarities march 11th
through the 13th
and after spokane washington march 18th
through march
20th tickets at f a t k z
dot com chappelle you're in kansas city
this weekend kansas city this weekend uh
the 25th through the 27th
and then uh i'll be in austin texas
march 5th and 6th
at the vulcan gas company yes sir brian
brian good to see you again buddy i love
you love you guys yeah
we're out